today we're talking about a new cloud
region a visual way to learn and behind
the scenes on spam filters i'm jenny
brown and welcome to this week in cloud
where we serve you the lowest latency
news
we're continuing to expand our global
footprint and we're doing it rapidly
in 2020 we announced our plans to launch
a new cloud region to help accelerate
the economic recovery and growth of
spain
with that we're excited to announce that
our new google cloud region in madrid is
officially open
having a new region in madrid helps
remove barriers to cloud adoption
allowing spanish businesses and
government entities to meet their
availability data residency and
sustainability needs in spain
our very own priyanka vergadia has
published a book of 101 visual
references for cloud engineers and
architects
after reading through thousands of pages
of google cloud documentation and
experimenting with virtually every
google cloud product she's distilled
that experience down to this book of
accessible bite-sized visuals
every day gmail's filtering capabilities
and advanced security protections help
billions of people stay safe and get
things done more efficiently
we've built a strong foundation and over
time we've continued to improve our
systems blocking more than
99.9 percent of spam phishing and
malware from ever even reaching your
inbox
learn more about how that all works on
the blog
if you want to read more about any of
these announcements or see a full list
check out the link
any thoughts or ideas leave us a comment
or tweet us we'll see it in the cloud
you